[Music]
hello Wolfgang today we are going to be
talking about a topic that has been
widely speculated Captain America's
death I've talked about this briefly in
previous videos that I've done but this
week
Captain America number 700 was released
just a heads up for a spoiler alert
about the issue if you have not read it
yet and possible spoilers for Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 if some of
my theories are correct also before we
get started don't forget to subscribe to
my channel because I have an army I have
an army we have a Hulk I personally
think that in Captain America number 700
they are doing some major foreshadowing
of what could happen in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 especially
because if they stick to somewhat of
this storyline Captain America can die
but still have a happy ending okay so
I'm going to do a very quick summary of
what happens in number 700 so if you
haven't read it yet and you plan on
reading it turn back now so what's
happening in this is America is
basically destroyed by a militia called
rampart rampart launched missiles on
basically nine-tenths of the United
States and now Captain America is left
to fight an unwinnable war so Bruce
Banner comes up with a plan to sin
Captain America back in time before he
was frozen before rampart launches their
missiles so he can stop them he was
supposed to send Captain America back a
week before he was frozen but instead
accidentally sends him back as he's
being frozen leaving him with only 10
minutes to stop the missile attack
Captain America is able to make it to
their leader but he still does not stop
the nuke from being launched so in true
Captain America fashion he jumps on the
missile and makes it explode causing the
rampart attack to never have happened
killing himself in the process then the
current time Captain America thaws out
wakes up and beats the rest of rampart
he has no idea that he's living in a
future made possible by his own death
it's kind of something to think about
Captain America saves the world by
sacrificing himself but still gets to
live on it hasn't been confirmed yet but
the fan hood mostly believes two things
that Captain America will die and to
that time travel will be involved
somewhat following this storyline from
the comics will really make fans happy I
think again Marvel is making Thanos out
to be the biggest baddest ruthless
villain that we've ever seen on screen
and Chris Evans has not renewed his
contract to play Captain America so
obviously it seems like he is going to
die but maybe this way the fans will
actually be ok with it and it would set
him up to go out as a true hero
sacrificing his life for the greater
good he was saved the world possibly the
universe he would save all of his
friends and then he would get a huge big
memorial so everybody could remember him
but this would also make it to where he
would still be alive in some time now
time travel is tricky there are many
things to consider such as like the
butterfly effect where if you affect one
thing in the past the whole entire
feature can be changed and I think if
that's how it would be in the movie then
that would be the ultimate goal to go
back in time to defeat Thanos in the
past that way if anybody has died in the
future they should be brought back to
life when they return to the future
again time travel is very complicated
subject to talk about and ultimately the
rooster brothers could do whatever the
heck they want to with the films but
here's a theory that I think could
possibly play out in Avengers infinity
war or Avengers 4 at the end of Captain
America Civil War there was obviously a
huge tear left in the relationship
between Captain America and Iron Man
it's been stated that this tension and
tear will continue throughout Avengers
infinity war they ultimately both love
each other and I think that Captain
America is going to sacrifice himself to
save Iron Man at some point during
Avengers infinity war most likely at the
end I think Danos will collect all of
the Infinity stones and wipe out half of
the universe and then the Avengers will
have to figure out some way to go back
in time to save everybody from here I
think a few Avengers will go back in
time including Iron Man The Hulk and
ant-man they'll then team up with the
current Avengers in the time that they
go to and they'll explain everything
that has happened in the future
including telling Captain America that
he dies from here they'll somehow figure
out a way to defeat Thanos and when the
Avengers go back to the present time
Captain America and all that he'll have
died will be back earth should be at
peace at that moment and Captain America
now knowing about time travel will be
sent
back in time to live with Peggy Carter
this would be satisfying on a few
different levels we could see Captain
America sacrifices own life to save his
best buddy Iron Man but still be in
Avengers 4 thanks to the time travel
he'd then be brought back at the end of
Avengers 4 which would satisfy everyone
who loves Captain America he would then
get his happily ever after by going back
in time and spending the remainder of
his years with Peggy Carter this would
then leave the mantle of Captain America
open for somebody to take such as Falcon
this would then start the new generation
of Avengers so this is my theory on what
could possibly happen with Captain
America and Avengers infinity war based
on the comics what do you guys think of
this theory possibly playing out and do
you have any theories of your own let me
know in the comments below I'd love to
hear from you be sure to give this video
a like and please be sure to subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers infinity war and join The Wolf
Gang thank you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]